peu
alors que j'arrivais à ramasser
déterminer
beau matin juillet le réveil a sonné dès
le lever du soleil
et j'ai dit à ma poupée autant secoué
c'est aujourd'hui tu le prends
on arrive sur le boulevard sans retard
pour voir défiler long
à deux ans si bas
et sur le champ on est refoulé par les
agents alors j'ai on n'est pas là pour
se faire engueuler on est là pour voir
le défilé on est
moi là pour se faire piétiner en est
pour voir le défilé si vous le monde
était resté chez soi ça ferait du tort à
la république
laissez-nous dans qu'on le regarde
sinon plus tard
reviendra manar
corner
le journal fait à julos mon poto genève
un petit bistrot ou louboutin beaujolais
vrai de vrai
ha
[Musique]
on est sorti très à l'aise mais voilà
j'ai eu l'idée de ramener chez moi
j'ai grand prix
ouais
free - sur la tête des mois pour se
faire engueuler on est là
on n'est pas là pour se rassurer on est
venu
oui
si tout le monde reste est lourdement
touchée ça serait une restée ce pack
royal ouvre cette forte et sent l'été
ne te steenois hausse en salle proche un
coup la marge en rentrant du tout ma
femme a gagné si forte
conte après passé le soir même eh ouais
trop à niveau fermé oui
il y avait quelques élus tirent en prêt
c'est toujours sympa jugé
on les refoule
sa mère
en danger
on n'est pas là pour se faire engueuler
on est
j'essayais lorient on est
sermonné
[Musique]
restée beaucoup de
tél
bah
alors on est plus en plus chez satan et
en france et n est pas tant ses
mouvements
car il est encore
mais n'est ce pas
denis
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]